- When an artist can dance,
that makes them a thousand times better
than anyone else.
- What's my dance experience like?
- Zero.
- None.
- I will say that I watch music videos,
and be like, "Oh, that looks easy."
- I chose iconic music video choreography,
not dance crazes, to show you
just how difficult your favorite
artist dance moves actually are.
How do you dance to
Thriller when you hear it?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- Dat dat dat, da dat.
- Ned, you have to learn.
Down, thrust, and forward.
- Can we really thrust?
- You've gotta really thrust.
- Okay.
- Are you not wearing shoes?
- Do I need shoes for this?
- Oh, God. You guys
are gonna be the worst.
- As a child of the 80s,
this is like muscle memory.
- It's hard to be a sexy zombie,
because zombies feel so dead.
- Michael Jackson was a sexy zombie.
- I know.
- We're gonna do it without
you, is that the thing?
- Yeah.
- No! No, no, no.
("Thriller" backbeat)
- That's a lost faster than
I thought it was gonna be!
I feel like with all these dances,
we're gonna see something
that caught on, that's like,
slightly complicated, it's not super easy.
- The moves just like,
make sense with the music.
- There's a reason why he was
the greatest entertainer
of our generation.
- The part that's easy
for everyone else to do,
is the only part you remember.
That was terrible!
- It was pretty perfect.
- What do you think vogueing looks like?
- This!
- [Girls] Vogue, vogue, vogue!
- Oh shit. Already unnatural.
Everything's always at a very sharp angle.
Oh, that hurts.
Voguing is both powerful, but elegant,
very smooth, but also super controlled.
- New Twitter bio.
- I'm all of those things.
- That's hot.
- Yes.
- Is it just arms, or do
we move our bodies too?
- You're delivering arms and face.
- Yes, bitch.
- Boom.
- No, that's--
- Yeah, that's not
happenin' for some of us.
- It's weird 'cause it's
sexy in a different way,
it's like, power sexy.
♫ Come on, vogue
- I feel empowered, the power of Madonna!
- It's hard to keep it all internal,
and like, keep a blank stare,
because you're doing so much work,
and you're just like, how are
you not breathing very hard?
- It'd be super easy to improv it,
but choreograph with other people?
That's hard.
- They do Vogue Battle, yes.
- Vogue Battle?
- Oh, oh, ey, ey, ey!
♫ Vogue vogue vogue ♫
- Bye bye bye!
(all cheering)
- I've got the Timberlake
bandana right now.
- I know part of it, it's this, right?
- Yeah, if you're lazy.
*NSYNC is very explosive.
Give it more swagger.
Stop being such a white boy.
No one seems to do this move quite right.
- Cause I'm over here, like,
yeah left, and then what?
- This is 90s pop!
- And I told you I was a horrible dancer.
- I'm a little confused, but it's okay.
- I'm not.
- Let's do this.
♫ Bye bye bye
♫ Bye bye
♫ Don't wanna be a fool for you
♫ Just another player ♫
- It's 100% attitude.
- That would've helped me in
my social life in high school.
- Wish I could do it one more time.
- That one was a lot of fun.
- I guess you just don't think
about how physical it can be.
It's kinda sad that most
of today's boy bands
don't dance like this anymore.
- I feel like I've learned
it one way so long,
that I thought this was the right way,
but it's really this, and
now when I try to correct it,
I'm like five seconds behind.
♫ Bye bye
(girl squealing)
- That was the best moment of my life!
- My wife and I went to a
Britney Spears concert in Las Vegas.
- Oops, Ned mentioned his wife again.
- It's already too much.
- I'm already lost!
- Looks like you're throwin' a
ball back at a baseball game.
- Chris, you're shimmying.
It's not that, it's this.
- Why is she walking like a chicken?
- A lot of this routine is
actually in forth position.
- Does anyone have ballet experience?
(bursts into laughter)
- Here.
- That's how you do it!
- Yeah.
- I never knew how she did it.
- What?
- What, nope, nothing.
Zero.
- What part are we on?
- [Together] Oh baby, baby, baby.
- Yeah, Keith, Keith! Fuck yeah!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thanks, Ned!
- Yeah.
- I thought the old lady
threw it in the ocean.
♫ Oops, I did it again ♫
- I feel like I've seen
"Oops, I did it again" a billion times
growing up, so it's
just a little bit easier
to lock into my mind.
- I feel like I'm in sixth grade again,
and I'm just dancing with my friends.
I literally got lost in this game.
- The movements mimic the lyrics.
- Maybe doesn't look
easy in the music video,
but I certainly didn't
think it was this hard.
- Brittney makes it look so easy though!
- I feel like 2007, Brittney.
(laughter)
- It's Janet Jackson.
- Yes!
- Is it the one where her
boob pops out during the Super Bowl?
- No.
- Yeah, 'cause I can do that one.
- Rhythm Nation.
(screaming)
- Oh, this video's intense, you guys.
- Three, second finger goes in,
- Oh, shit.
- then these two fingers.
- Dang.
- We're not gonna flip it off?
- Nope.
- She wasn't that dystopian, huh?
- And I bet this happened really fast.
(screaming)
- The reason many people
can't do a Janet dance,
is because they are so damn hard.
She has really complex dances.
Make your face hard. Make
your face hard, Zach.
- The actual tempo is,
Bum bum bum, bum buh.
- No.
(laughing nervously)
- No!
- You can fight someone with that.
- It's so fast and precise,
it's gonna be done by the time
you realize I'm fucking it up.
- Janet, this one's for you, baby.
♫ Five, four, three, two, one ♫
- It was incredibly fast and technical.
- I just know people were in classes
for months, to learn her stuff.
- Yeah, this is hard, but it's fun.
- It felt like a military music piece.
- I just wanna apologize to Miss Jackson,
if she ever sees this.
- What is Beyonce's most famous
choreographed music video?
- Single Ladies.
- Ladies.
- We're gonna look like
some moms at a concert.
- If we're gonna be Beyonce,
we can't do it in flats.
(groaning)
- No.
- I can't even walk in heels!
- Well you're gonna love this, then!
- Right, left right.
- Oh, I already feel a blister coming!
- Be ready to catch me,
I might fall on you.
- You got this.
- Wait, there are arms, too?
- This is the hardest dance we've done!
- And that's it!
- Uh, no.
And, roll to the left.
- No!
- Oh, no, no!
(clapping)
- Sit in the heel.
- No!
- I can't body roll.
- I can't, I will bust an ankle, ya'll.
- Eugene's a better woman than all of us!
- I'm gonna fall over.
(laughing)
- All of these dances
you think are so easy,
and then the little, I'm so impressed.
♫ Oh oh oh
♫ Oh oh oh, oh oh oh
♫ Oh oh oh ♫
- It's incredibly difficult,
I can't imagine singing and
doing this at the same time.
- To do it in heels, I have
so much more respect for,
not only women in general,
but women performers particularly.
- Looks sexy as hell in the music video,
and we look like--
- Like we had too much
to drink at book club.
- We're a bunch of Michelles,
in a world that belongs to Beyonce.
- It's a little girl
dancing, so if she can do it,
we'll have no problem, right?
- Yeah, she's like--
- Shes a professional dancer,
who has crazy acrobatic skills.
- We're gonna do one of the simpler parts.
- Oh, it's the--
- It's the stuff with the table.
- I love this part!
- And seven, and punch!
- Woah.
- And your head slams on the table.
- Shit.
- Like that.
- Not gonna be able to do it.
- I'm too tall.
- This dance is not made
for people with glasses.
- Pull your own head up.
- This is dope.
- And your face is going like, mm.
And you grab it!
- Wah!
- And you throw it away!
And you go weh-meh-meh-meh, meh-meh-meh!
Then you're gonna be a tiger!
(roaring)
In your cage.
And, I'm pregnant.
- He could be making
this up as he went along.
- This is important. Don't
punch me in the face.
♫ Guess I'm just holding on for tonight
♫ Help me, I'm holding on for dear life ♫
- That was the most fun.
- It just came from emotion.
- We were attaching it to
things, instead of numbers.
- It's sort of like speaking,
there's a bunch of different
ways you can say something,
but it still is the same message.
- It takes time and work to like--
Just like any art.
- We were definitely like, the best group
at Buzzfeed dancing, right?
(silence)
- [All] Yay!
- Thank you!
- This is a godddamn job,
to learn how to do this.
- You gotta sing, dance, look sexy.
- Also, girls, learn to code.
That's what we learned.